what in the world is that instrument
that plays in mob psycho 100 you know
the one with the psychic theme it's this
this instrument is called a sea moons it
sounds wrong to say and by instrument I
guess I really mean robot Abomination
with artificial lungs and throat capable
of making that weird kazoo-like singing
we hear this thing was invented by meiwa
denki who was actually the inventor of
the automatone this dude is a literal
music Willy Wonka who invents nonsense
instruments as he so calls them
and so Kenji Kawai the guy behind the
ost4 mob psycho 100 seems to have a
particular interest in Sea moons as this
is not even the first time he uses one
in his work and contracted denki for the
production of mob psycho 100 score this
instrument brings such an incredibly
unique flavor to this piece there really
is a sense of profound power and Terror
that is conveyed with its musical output
which certainly makes sense given how
terrifying the instrument that carves
out the song looks